eighty-one players 1783 average rating
time handicap 30 minutes cube fanatics
here we go I am entered I did not forget
matha graph get this thing out of here
no matter what
efore let's get f4 in the mix pawn push
kick that night away get out of there
and now there's the possibility for
sacks on h7 I want to get to f6 oh it's
my move
oh they gonna resign I lost track right
there back to tournament maybe that was
a good thing they were in free move mode
Oh
Todorov 'ok not the first time we have
played oh that's not a good start
no it's not you gotta remember if it's
your move or not
shame on you smarten up this guy knows
the story he definitely knows the story
definitely he has seen it before and
he's probably gonna see it again
Oh Knight f3 is TKO this move is needed
it's a necessity but I get this move
uh-oh bad news let's give a check I
probably shouldn't have done that I
should just take in the rook while I had
the chance okay let's go over here let's
go each for break it open come on Queen
you know you want to play mmm got the
Queen I don't want to take the Queen
though let's take here I got the Jeep on
next okay this is still working out here
my bishop right here avoid any tricks
push this ponder Victory Lane let's come
up here
let's get that night out of there whoo I
shouldn't approve of that
get that 85 do that let's give a check
no no no no oh that's a nasty pin there
in a pen they can't get out of it uh-oh
oh the tricky nights around though
another pin
let's go away let's go Jeep on your past
past pons must be pushed oh I got the
night run run run run run run run
they're gonna resign resign time hang on
cut the King off stepladder step the
ladder step the ladder back to
tournament six six six and a bunch of
two's 27 and change here we go Jaden
Jaden six five four one is Jaden a mover
or a non mover ooh
they might resign they might end up
getting forfeited within 15 seconds I
think there's a new like rule if I'm not
mistaken there might be a quick forfeit
after 15 seconds come on business isn't
that supposed to be one of the changes
on chess cube if you double the points
and they don't and they don't move or
something or no no no it's um if the
game starts and they don't move without
doubling the points then they're
forfeited so now at least I get double
the points if they're not gonna move I
think that's that's the that's the order
that's what I meant to say so okay I'm
okay with them waiting one minute just
to get double the points that's that's
not too bad give me those points
give me that confetti here we got maybe
I should have been doing some homework
one minute bullit homework on some other
people instead of commenting on the
different changes back to tournament
1212 and bunches
sixes and ala for right here Bruce
Xavier Bruce Xavier all right let's get
this night out of there
Tom push now you have this okay I have a
past pun but there blockading I mean I
should play this okay let's stop there
Bishop from coming out
let's stop be forward stop it stop it I
just saw them like I was getting angry
stop it stop doing that move if the
Queen goes too far you know what could
happen I could take on h3 maybe oh oh
don't go too far Queen she went too far
overloaded Panaji uh-oh there's a g4 at
the night kick them away that can't be
right can it
give me that rook why isn't it moving
stupid mouse stupid Mouse okay things
are okay I think that's just gonna be
ripped check but I have King h7 and I
could take the rook with my queen if
rook takes rook that's why I had to UM
run the numbers on that well that's why
it took forever oh just give me this
party
give me that pawn it's still pretty even
here oh now I have a good home for my
bishop hang on hang on let's give a
check let's get this beep on Oh bishop
take no bishop check bishop check bishop
check on the king there sidestep in that
lets go upon your past
get moving get moving
yes yes yes yes I got the rook clock
situation
oh I'm in check get out of there let me
just throw this check in just for fun
get them either move back here right
here anything give a check okay dude
they're down on turn or they're down on
tournament they're down in time you know
what I meant
all right let's go a lot of time left
we're only seven minutes into this Oh
dark squares dark squares give me them
give me them give me them get that night
out of there
oh the night is officially trapped
it's a cooked night cook tonight
variation here develop Queen d2
queenside castle actually let's defend
the night first inside castle let's do
this actually forget about the H pawn
move to get my knight up here how do I
capture and go like this trade
LightScribe bishops and then get my
queen do a six somehow and then my
knight to be five f6
I have that seems like a pretty decent
gnome
maybe I could get my a pawn rolling this
pond is gonna have pressure soon oh I
have a lot a lot of support now get my
pawn to a6 and my queen to b7 oh the
Queen's dead resign resignation same
thing thirty thirty twenty eighteen
sixteen X X man spaz 1988 okay let's go
here I have a two two is two to one
majority in the center oh look at me try
to do it now it's right now yeah there
you go analyzable game you know I just
don't know as that bullet came you have
plenty of time to do that
okay you have a two-to-one majority in
the center okay now it's a now it's a 3l
majority
okay let's support this Oh I'm dropping
that pun Oh Queen check a Rooskies right
here could happen okay
this night is gonna be a pain or is he
let's just go here my queen can take the
night how am i doing are they gonna take
that really um I'm gonna try this give
it a check a risky check be afraid
uh-oh this is actually working out got
the rook and maybe the other rope let's
give a check first
another check and then a rook check if
the Queen blocks oh now this is um
where's the main right here's mate next
if they move back to tournament forty
two forty two thirty two thirty oh tight
pack right here forty two forty two
thirty - this guy has given me beatings
guy in third oh the beat me to the punch
here oh I should have gone with the
fantasy let's avoid that exchange easy
now support this Center let's get my
bishop out oh just take a bishop if it's
free take free bishops what's the matter
with you take free bishops don't you
take that bishop on D was lovely it
would have been lovely let's do this I
want to be able to take oh okay that
Knights gonna be a pain I can feel it
sneakiness everywhere sneakiness
everywhere ah pins night city night city
is he trapped no he's not
yes he is oh that was a free piece that
was a free piece straight nights tricky
nights tricky nights tricky nights get
that night out of there he is definitely
very tricky
now he's offsides get out of there night
he's so tricky get out of there
I just cared that tricky tonight tricky
nights everywhere oh I had a fork too
many missed moves come on you could get
this can't you mouse slips everywhere
Mouse slipper Rooskies everywhere check
another check push your pond you know
you want to push your pond watch out for
steel me it's not gonna be stalemate
what am i doing can I get this pond
please what am I doing with that move
push push push push
I don't have any time where did my time
go can I get this pond there was an
easier way to do it wasn't there wasn't
there an easier way to do it can I get
my Knights out of here run to Victory
Lane I can't move watch out for steel me
why'd I do that with my Queens it's a
draw I had so much material and so many
miss mouse clicks
oh no you can't have a draw and still
win ah my Knights I just I just want
them to die in that position they were
just in the way I do my little
stepladder thing ah okay pull it
together now pull it together you know
what's coming up no you want to take
that 9h to back to tournament land a
quick kill fear the fishing pole ah a
rebound a rebound a ruski ah okay hang
on oh hang on gather yourself gather
yourself get that night out of there
he's a bad man watch out for Bishop c5
tricks watch out for the tricky Knights
Knights were so tricky
now one night he only had one night but
boy was he tricky I just want to get rid
of him for the longest time he wouldn't
go you would not go away oh hang on oh
hang on what's happening in this game
okay I know what's happening I have
everything covered I think okay
mmm get out of there clean leave the
defense of the bishop Oh for carros keys
before they were smell a melon what was
happening
kick the Queen away get the Queen again
I'm on age seven and f7o I'm on this or
is this a good move
don't fall for me whatever gets cool oh
there's Knight g6 maybe oh that's
looking pretty decent Navy
maybe whoa okay a lot scarier than I
would like
I only have 11 seconds oh my queen is
hit bishop oh I have Jags though tricky
Knights the Queen can't take no give
another check over here check actually
that's not check h8 you know you want to
be the h8 please say it is they're gonna
move their Jeep and on I don't know what
to do if they do what they did they just
go anywhere even if it's wrong even if
it's wrong just move just move just move
just move come on 72 6661 oh we're only
halfway there we're only halfway there
less than 15 my ponen is throwing the
bird at me right here giving me the bird
here knight c6 d 5 let me just get rid
of my light square bishop could we
please just do that please let's just do
that
let me get here can I make that happen
we're gonna see about that
light scrub bishops please come off ok
let's not capture here and open the F
file okay my knight is not gonna get to
d3 so forget about that forget about it
get your gun be Oh heavy fire on the a
file let's get Castle the position is
opening up
man then that Bishop is a pain no he's
not
I'm on this in watching over c5 I have
this advance let's go for it
I'm dropping this pond rRNA no no I'm in
a fork he'd take this knife first if I
took here there'd be 97 he's passed he
needs to be captured I was that was well
said right there he's passed he needs to
be captured okay I'm on this no no no no
take with the rook
nice and easy take this check a ruski
where's the main looking for it that's
me no the Queen has to come back
immediately clean has to give herself up
she has to go to f1 rook here that's the
comment at the center right there rook
here do I really want to do that okay
let ten seconds let's go here
come on King there's no mate why am I
trying why am i fishing for me there's
no mate actually I got the rook though
okay come on let's see if I can make
decent mouse moves right here come on
Mouse mate are they gonna move over no
they're down on time ninety ninety 8472
mag the group Grievous all right yes
okay let's go at four no maybe not
let's just get the F file open like this
maybe no they gonna take my bishop like
mouth slipped right there I would have
been mated oh I would have got loud
right there okay now I've 95 Queen
Esther run home she too good for her own
she's too good for her home I'm dropping
G oh hang on I don't like the thought of
that I'll just take the pine and just
defend on G - no I should take in the
rook at Queen f3 after the Queen takes
what's going on with the knight forgot
the
that was covered get out of there before
you cause me a problem on this square oh
oh just take a free queen would you play
me I was on the Queen with my night ah
okay it's still alright it's gonna be
okay it's gonna be okay
easy does it get active here you don't
need the castle they can't get this pond
otherwise there's back ranked maids
they're gonna go after my rook then I
get me I could have taken the ruck as
well
this is mate though I have this sealed
off night in pond back to tournament
110 109 who's this 110 109 104 10
minutes and change remaining chess Skype
just Skype
all right all right Knight f6 you know
what's happening here you could smell it
you could smell it smells smells fishy
here ah I got the docs for a bishop at
least alrighty
no uh-uh there would have been a knight
sac on b5 if I played Bishop there I
think so let's not and say we did I
should have done a pawn push let's try
it now and now this move uh-oh there
might be sneakiness happening at the
night
Wow there's got to be a good move here
what's that oh I got the Queen there
should have been something better right
away I'm give a check why are you trying
to retreat attack think forward why are
you going in Reverse man what's my
bishop doing he's still sitting on his
home square stupid bishop oh how the
rooks gonna play here ah man ah man
okay I got it how's the clock situation
ah look at the time cuz you can't win
and any other way no other way I open
this up here okay my bishop is active
passed pawn he's fast
I should have dropped that pond he's
dead now he's a dead pawn anything this
game is not gonna finish anything
whoa okay back to tournament 131 29 whoa
one point this guy again let's go E for
eight minutes and change I have a
one-point lead
Wow a nail-biter who's gonna win
I had a speed bump earlier it's for sure
let's go with 83 maybe okay
what could do that you know you want a
castle you know you know you want to get
that night out of there how about and
then I can recapture on eat whoa hmm I
better just gas castle right there
there's gonna be night tricks night
discover checks and get that guy out of
there
whoa okay drop piece it's still there if
castles happens that file can open up f6
I have a queen Czech Queen Czech Queen
check
I still have Bishop takes I think it's
not really working let's try this it's a
clock situation ok I have two bits a
bunch of pieces pointing right at my
opponents King are they gonna Castle
alright let's go after them Queen h5 is
happening it's definitely happening
Bishop takes upon blocks this is this is
happier this is me this is happening
this is happening okay it's happening
where does that mean and get the Queen
first and then just move my knight so I
could get my Queen here where is the
main why can't there be a simpler may I
I probably missed a bunch of mates
already Bishop has to block back to
tournament that one took forever 150 150
150 to 150 150 there's two people ahead
Queen sacker oh not the Queen sacker
okay six minutes and change there's two
up there oh oh they're hanging on to be
enough they're being greedy right there
they want to hang on to their pawns
they're hanging on to them
okay come on I need two quick I need two
quick what does that mean
he's the quick win come on you're gonna
miss it you're gonna miss it you're
gonna miss it you're not gonna miss it
you sniffed that one right out okay
light squares where are you what's
hanging out of that night and can I get
that light square bishop I'll be great I
would love to have that happen whoa what
happened there I just want a piece and a
rook next I'll resign a quick resigner
I'm in first 170 150 to 155 minutes and
change
what I needed double those points here
we go here we go move okay what's this
creepy-crawler okay h4 it's happening
again it's happening again it's
happening again
actually there's Knight f6 at the end of
this they can't take that night in that
variation Knight f6 defends now it's
undefendable uh-oh
just move just move it to mate no matter
what you know you want to move or resign
one of the two anything right here no
matter what right here no matter what
don't be an odd move earn Ally no now
don't create a name for yourself now you
you definitely want to move or resign
Nally the non mover no Oh commander kill
me now Lee yes now he's okay no he's
okay ah put the fear in him or or she I
don't know okay hang on hang on I have a
lead alright now he was not only was
good recognizing that there was no good
thing there okay Bishop g4 Bishop g4 let
me take that night oh boy can I get b5
in please no shut down and as usual I
don't know what I'm doing setup oh can I
give a check oh that Knights gonna kill
me
let's get this off Knights coming to c6
it's gonna be a disaster that there goes
that pun yeah he's still dead let's get
my night doing something can I take that
night away he's still dead by the way I
don't know why I don't think to defend
him haha I must care that much about him
I really just don't care about that guy
do i stake here he's past right it's a
good thing it could still be taken but I
get this guy whoo whoo Forks Forbes
everywhere watch out for the forks
I might land in the fork
hang on hang on hang on I might want to
try to smother make combo get my queen
here or something
what is that night doing he's being a
pest my queen close to trapped whoa
she's close to trapped whoa whoa whoa
hang on here hang on here
oh there's Ponte alright there's clean
taste you know what I meant I have a
time edge though hit the night oh what's
he doing okay get out of there
hit the rope oh go here I don't know why
go here I don't know why but I'm gonna
go there
hit the pond they don't have time do
they know give me this pawn here the
rook back rank means take the knight you
know you want to take them that was a
bad move no it's not it might be a good
move back rank mates tricky mates
they're down on time back to term at
2:10 whoa 210 192 if somebody wins again
though there's only two minutes I gotta
get this win I definitely have to get
this win I can't I can't hope that
somebody else doesn't win I got a I have
to control my own destiny here yeah so
dramatic their control your own destiny
Oh back to tournament to 3,200 one
minute 48 remaining no no no 143 I am
okay I have to win within like 30
seconds all right excuse me I have to
win I can't let my time get down below
10 seconds or something like that okay
so we have a stone wall and then my
queen over here maybe Bishop d7 I want
to get my light square Bishop off the
board just take my light square bishop
he's terrible
let's get that guy out of there okay
watch out for this never you deal watch
out for that take this rook get a queen
trade here
Queen trades please I just want to clean
trade it's probably probably be taken
I'm not moving quick enough are they
gonna move there's only 40 cent okay I
just want the Queen's off they could
probably take this pond and it's good
and take my queen 23 seconds got the
Queen I'm just coming here and close it
up and reroute my Bishop where do you
want to live over here he wants to live
right here I think no matter what get
the bishops off anything
rook here rook here I could definitely
rely upon that get the rooks off over
here Knight here trade rooks get my
Knight to f5 let's give it a check how
much time how much time there's only
seven seconds just do anything anything
there's check they don't have any time
they're down on time are they down at
they're down on time 250 220 the
tournament's complete the time just
right now Oh boots oh they're making me
play another one though don't make me
play yeah this ah this thing out of here
they're making me play I got the
confetti yes I could ask for look in
fetty's right here confetti is happening
let me um it's right here look at that
the clock is ticking though I another
one of these where you have to play out
I don't have to play oh this is all I
was looking for I'm not looking for an
extra game right here this is all I
wanted it's all about the paper if you
didn't know ah they're just letting
their clock tick I might get a W this is
just this is just a bonus a bonus now
move around oh man oh they are moving we
have action
less than 30 they better kick it into
high gear right now
I'm gonna play this one out let this be
it
please they're flying now they're flying
they're not gonna expect me taking that
are they you get that pun I'm on Evan
Forks more Forks biggest fork right here
I'm on the clean castle f45 another fork
kill the piece get the clean active here
no matter what
push pond they resigned I got a I got
270 they're not recording it though okay
that's where it stands
oh man good games up to fifty two twenty
two twelve two hundred 197 it was pretty
tight and then I had a quick resigner
late so that was a I was a big boost
right there